hi guys it's ria today i'm going to
recreate a recipe from the game called
cooking mama i did this one time and it
was a lot of fun so i want to do a game
last time when we did this we came
across this youtube channel called game
team and he recreate a lot of cooking
mama recipes go check him out he makes a
lot of fun videos i don't play a lot of
video games but our producer katie does
so she picked the recipe for me hello
are you ready yes okay it's it's called
the flower
i don't it's french i don't know just
put it there and i'm sorry just in the
comments tell me how to pronounce it
so you just hit the make button and then
you go for it all right i'm gonna leave
but if you need any help just you holler
i'll be over there okay
so okay make okay mix it with the
blender this okay
oh
wait till it's calm and then you throw
in the
voice
okay and then go in go in
go ahead no
when it goes to the green okay okay then
[Music]
[Laughter]
shorts in the kitchen yeah no no no okay
kind of go a little faster oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
great job great job there's jelly
i think those are strawberries okay so
now no
it's not motion sensor
no no you go you go like
fast
yeah yeah
yes
no
you're almost there you're almost there
yes
yes
okay great job okay here we go go go go
go go
yes
i am stressed for you oh this is the fun
part okay
you have to move things in the fridge so
you can fit that in you can move the
tuna what is that can you think you can
move stuff up
oh new stuff okay maybe move some of
this stuff up to the top shelf i don't
think that's fast
and then move can connect oh that can go
in now they knew we needed help they
were like
make it easy
so this you're gonna go up and down to
shake it out yeah no too hard
you flew it out of the room
yeah
isn't that beautiful it's pretty
that's it you did it i'm sorry i left
thank you
so now we play the game and i'm going to
get ingredients and we are going to
recreate flour bubble oil
in the video game cookie mama made a
cream first it seems like she poured
into unsaid gelatin it's not the
practical way so i'm going to make jelly
part first in the video game there is no
recipe so i'm going to show you how to
make it step by step first i'm going to
bloom gelatin when you're making gelatin
dessert you want to bring gelatin first
to activate i have hot water cup and a
half hot water adding into sugar we have
3 4 sugar i'm going to dissolve this
completely now i'm adding one tablespoon
lemon extract for flavoring so gelatin
has broomed so i'm going to add in hot
water so gelatin is going to completely
melt
when you're trying this at home and the
gelatin didn't melt completely you can
use microwave or you can melt it over
the stove i have ice one cup of water
now i'm going to pour this into the
gelatin bowl so it will set faster so
ice has melted but i kind of see the
bits of
gelatin so i'm going to strain it
so now it's time to get mold and
strawberries i have jelly it's ready and
i have silicone mold and in the video
game there are red ingredients i think
it's strawberries so we have
strawberries and we have beautiful
edible flowers so i'm going to fill this
mold i'm gonna go
halfway
so it seems like there were four
strawberries do you play video games now
right you know you don't only think i
play to mario kart
you don't like driving though in real
life yes it has been my new year's
resolution for five years drive on the
highway maybe we do a mario kart game
for and practice
so in the video game mama made me throw
flowers but we don't have machine hands
so katie is going to do it for me
okay ready go
wow i did you're much better you're much
better
too much too much
oh my god you're left that was
shockingly i am shocked
there's more flowers one side another
side it's empty it's almost like a
wedding blessing
[Laughter]
how would you rate this as practicality
practicality
one
and i have two more so i'm gonna just do
normal you're going to unmold upside
down so you want to put the pretty side
down i want to put kind of different
colors another thing
if you're doing a home
you don't want to put too much flour
like i saw because flowers are pretty
but it's not tasty so in the video
cooking mama didn't set this jelly but
in real life you want to set this jelly
at least 30 minutes in a refrigerator
in the video game i think cooking mama's
stan mixer had some trouble it was going
super fast and super slow so i hope
cooking mama will fix her standard mixer
but i have the standard mixer that works
i have three egg yolks and i'm going to
mix it a little bit
you just want to mix just like couple
seconds just break the egg yolks now i'm
going to add sugar little by little with
low speed
hot milk
i'm adding vanilla in the video game she
used from the bottle if i do that i'm
not sure how much i'm adding i just
wanted to add a two teaspoon
so let me do it
this off
and i'm gonna mix a little bit and then
i'm gonna add
gelatin i think game one is a little bit
more
soft
we will see if it's gonna melt
[Music]
let's check so i still see a big chunk
of gelatin and we also use raw egg so i
want to make this babaroa cream
as a traditionally i make so i'm going
to heat up over the stove i'll be right
back right so i
moved the mixture onto the stove so you
want to constantly mix until all the
gelatin and sugar is dissolved and make
sure it doesn't burn or cut drink so the
mixture is thick and it's ready so i
want to make this cream very smooth so
i'm straining all right so let's move on
to the next step of the game
alright so i have hot cream i'm going to
cool this over ice and i want to lower
the temperature to room temperature and
you want to constantly
start so it will cool quicker i think
mama is a
maximalist
and i'm more like a minimalist so
you know like we can be friend but i
think we are we have a different taste
so it came down to room temperature so
i'm going to add heavy cream into this
if you follow traditional bavaroa recipe
you are going to whip the cream so it's
become more airy but in the video game
she combined heavy cream and whipped and
then she whipped the mixture so i'm
going to follow halfway i think it looks
good
you just want to whip until very thick
and i'm straining so um
extra air bubble it's not going to get
into the mixture next we are going to
fill the malt
i'm going to pour
barbarian cream into
jelly but i'm going to show you this is
onset jelly just like how cooking mama
did and we will see if it's gonna make a
nice two-layer cake do you think it will
i don't think so
okay okay
so as you can see it's
kind of
incorporating in a weird way so it's not
giving a nice two layers so it didn't
work
so we are going to pour onto the set
gelatin
so we can make nice two layer cake and
i'm gonna pour like just like mama did
[Music]
thanks
okay well done
i'm trying not to overfill like i did on
the game okay
all right so i'm going to put this in a
refrigerator
but katie want me to
recreate the video game scene where i'm
doing fridge tetris
so we're gonna do them next
all right
i don't know why canned tuna is in the
refrigerator
i'm gonna put
that
it's so easy five stars
all right so the final step is i'm
molding the cake if i follow cooking
mama's way we are just shaking the mold
and i'm very skeptical
but let's do anyway
it's not too bad it's not too bad so i
will show you the better way
so i think the best way to unmold the
gelatine dessert is dipping into hot
water because gelatin melts right lay
over moment of truth
yes
[Music]
it's even better than mama's oh this is
so beautiful
it's so pretty it's so colorful
it's very jiggly
how about taste
it's really good creamy on the bottom we
put lemon extract so it has nice citrus
flavor if i'm making this for second
time i'm going to whip cream instead of
combine heavy cream and mixture together
and whip because um the
bubbler is a little bit dense i want it
a little bit airy but overall tastes
really good i will give this 2.8 stars
out of three thank you so much for
watching and please comment below what
cooking mama recipe you want me to try
bye
[Music]
you